jake deckard you played telltale Batman
telltale the Batman series realm of
shadows the fam in the taupe ulcers
realm of shadows I did I played it so
did two more yeahh two more Hussein over
in the UK reviewed it gave it a eight
liked a lot but you played it yesterday
right I played it yesterday I think he
liked it more than I did I'm I think I'm
a little more burnt out on the telltale
games than he is though mm-hmm and I
might crash like six times while playing
it so on PC other people try it out to
more than have any issues um Joey tried
it out didn't have any issues but for
some reason maybe it was just the pc
configuration just it crashed six times
so that kind of ruined my experience but
I mean it's a typical telltale first
episode it's good if you like Batman
you're gonna like it yeah I remember you
just said you were saying that you kind
of tired of telltale games which is
where I'm at and I want to bring Scott
eggs I know you play a lot easy my I was
never super into those kind of games to
begin with I recognize their like
writing quality and their narrative
strengths and kind of you know the
illusion of choice they give you and I
really like walking dead season one the
wolf among us i also finished that but
for Batman what's like if you're a
Batman fan is there a lot to like here
if you're not just like a Telltale Games
fan yeah I think Batman fans are really
gonna like it it tells i'm not i'm not
super familiar with the comics I've seen
the movies and it tells somewhat of a
different story one thing that two more
pointed out was that it tells like the
stories trying to break Bruce Wayne
rather than the Batman so instead of
like putting Batman through the ringer
it's more about putting Bruce Bruce
Wayne through the ringer and there's
like a lot of crap happens to him this
game and it'll be really interesting to
see where it goes from there mm-hmm and
this does set up all that pretty nicely
but I mean if you want like a it's not
all it's not action packed though at
least not yet like there's not a whole
lot of like Batman beating up thugs it's
still there but it's not as prevalent is
maybe some people hoped easy for those
games is always kind of liked or sorry
the action for those games always kind
of like q te have you right and it is
for this too and like one thing that's
kind of weird I don't remember being
like this in the walking dead or wolfram
but when one weird thing is that like
you can straight-up just not hit buttons
and just play through it and then if you
don't hit enough of them after a while a
guy I'll just like shoot you or
something we'll be like the end but
Batman will still like beat the snot out
of people you if you don't hit anything
so it's not like he's actually messing
things up just kind of weird I came over
and saw you like just like leaning back
in your seat kind of like every once in
a while when you're prompted just
pressing the e key to shoot your back it
didn't look particularly engaged so that
was like my third time playing through
that parts that may have been why I
looked pretty uninterested but he did
look very good but yeah like it sounds
like it's kind of delivering what we
want from a telltale Game right that
narrative I don't know Scott you're you
have you played like all the Telltale's
properties by this point I don't think
I'll ago played all of them because
they've been making games for a long
time but I've been keeping up pretty
closely since the first season the
walking dead like seasons one and two
the walking dead wolf among us I didn't
ever finish game thrones but tells in
the borderlands was on my favorite games
from last year and yet it's they're not
they're not mechanic heavy games if you
are looking for action you are
absolutely in the wrong place and it
sounds like Batman's approach which I
have not had a chance to play yet
unfortunately but it sounds like the
approach they take to action is similar
to but not exactly like their previous
games you're right that in previous
games you actually hats like hit buttons
or you would fail like if you missed one
or two button presses like the you know
you would die or something bad would
happen it would kick you back to the
beginning of the section so it sounds
like you can kind of get away with a
little bit more here but um two more
actually pointing this out in his in his
review that it wouldn't really fit the
character of he was just getting beat up
by regular old thugs right so it was
kind of a weird line for a telltale to
walk like it wouldn't make sense for him
to just be like missing punches and
getting worked over by thugs just
because you missed a button prompt so I
can kind of see how they were caught in
a tricky situation there but then again
like maybe they just should skip over
this action stuff all together like if
it's if it's still not really that
engaging if it still does quick time
events and people really aren't that
into it maybe they need to really just
recognize where their skills lie
continue to focus and invest more in the
storytelling and the decision making and
less on the QTE is it'll be interesting
to see how they sort of like evolve
their approach to combat for Batman over
the course of the series but there's a
chance that it won't change it
honestly I'm a lot more interested in a
walking dead season 3 that seems like
that might change things a lot more but
that's not that's not for a few more
months till yeah that's the thing every
time they announce a new property which
I feel like they have a lot now Batman
was the first one was like what are they
doing but that doesn't seem like the
Lego stuff or not the Lego The Game of
Thrones stuff the wolf among us that
made sense like I what was the minecraft
minecraft maybe I sorry not Lego yeah my
gosh core mode yeah which they're not
bad they're qu so I just don't this
seems like my initial impression when I
first heard Eliza's properties that are
forcing these narratives on things I
wouldn't want a narrative and like
walking dead makes sense it's a like a
post-apocalyptic zombie world we've
become accustomed to that kind of trope
by now wolf among us the same thing
based on the graphic novels of fables
fable i'm not mistaken but then Game of
Thrones comes along but Batman that's
the one that I actually that's the one
I'm most drawn to I love Game of Thrones
but I want to get into Batman like you
said they're kind of like trying to put
Bruce Wayne through the ringer and I
really like that idea of after a while
is Batman really the mask or is that the
real one and then Bruce Wayne is the
actual character do they really set up
any like kind of cool character studies
in this game are like two heads they're
gonna extend through with what five
episodes I'm assuming yeah i think is a
typical five episodes but yeah they do
so they do like i said they do set up
Bruce Wayne an interesting way and
Batman is kind of just there to beat up
beat up thugs like when Bruce Wayne
can't do something it's like all right
Batman and then you do quick time events
which actually you can you can't fail
them if that wasn't clear it's just like
it's very lenient but then there's also
a new character well not a new character
he's uh he's people know him I don't
want to spoil it but they introduce him
in a very different way which is also
something that two more mentioned in his
review which I think could be really
interesting later down the line or it
could just fall flat as if now is pretty
interesting and then you know you've got
your typical characters like Selina Kyle
Catwoman that kind of play like very
similar to what you'd expect but once
again like I feel like they are planting
seeds to do something more with these
characters which is interesting I think
Batman fans are really gonna like it do
they push the detective angle and
investigating because I feel like that
that was they they used it for
Rocksteady's games and that made those
some cool like fun ways like you know
described them as the greatest detective
in the
older whatever do they do that with the
telltale games I feel like they're like
tailor made for this kind of slower pace
they do and I think that's probably like
the most successful parts when you're
Batman there's still relatively simple
like you're not gonna get stuck on one
of these for a while but it's like
you'll go into a room and there'll be
all this like evidence laying around and
basically you need to connect different
pieces of evidence to each other and
then like a sort of I forget what it's
called but like a holographic recreation
will play it out for Batman mm-hmm and
the viewer and you can kind of like see
like okay this is what's going on it's
actually pretty gory to like some of
these crime scenes well the only
investigating one but the one you
investigate is it's pretty gory like
this is this amateur mature Batman story
if people were interested do they kind
of they've mentioned the multiplayer did
you get to try that at all or is that
like you did try it can you use a nice
try just talking laughter is not
encouraging no can you how does it tell
tale game first off like just describe
it to us because I really don't even
know how a telltale Game would have
multiplayer so you know like jack box TV
mm-hmm so it's similar to that and that
you get a code you go to a website on
your phone and then you enter the code
give yourself a name and then you can
vote on things to say and then when
there's nothing to say you can either
thumbs up or thumbs down the scene I
don't know we didn't quite figure that
out you just thumbs up and thumbs
downing random stuff but basically
whenever there's a dialog choice
everyone in the room can pick like what
choice they want to say from their phone
and now Batman will say it and yes I was
a majority rule or is it just like
somebody who's driving we'll we'll look
and see what the majority rule really
though Alex thought he was testing out
with me and he thought that I still got
to pick because I was mouse and keyboard
turns out though like we had three
people vote for one thing and I voted
for the other and that one went with it
so it is democratic really just that
because that that's really interesting
that it like if you commit to having
other people with you that they are like
they are in your game they are taking
control you are really in it together
yeah I would just be one of those people
trying to derail the entire thing not to
just be control but like I don't if it's
a democratic thing I just want to
actually try to upset the balance i
guess i guess i am gonna watch the zone
well like i just thought i was major
than i define myself i thought yeah but
you
the problem with it though is that well
I mean like if you did something like
this what would you typically want to do
with this like stream it right mm-hmm
you can't stream it though because
decisions you have got eight seconds and
that lags not gonna quick enough yeah so
I mean the the easy thing would be just
to get rid of the timer mm-hmm but for
some reason they didn't do that so you
can't really stream this you have to
like have a separate stream for the
decisions and then like a delayed one
for the actual choices yeah see that's
already too much work know it's gonna do
this is good but tell tales said that
they are trying to figure out a way so
people can stream it just kind of a
shame that they haven't figured that out
because that seems like the main appeal
for something like yes like I'm not
gonna invite my friends over and like
let's watch Batman telltale as we pick
to sit like I don't know it just makes
sense yeah I don't know I I don't I like
Batman a lot like a lot of people do
nowadays but I don't know that a lot of
times the telltale games I have nothing
against them they're just I think
they're very well written I think like I
said I'd like that the choice is carried
through to the end I like the episodic
structure I think it worked well here I
just always feel like I could get that
experience from another medium I don't
know like I like narrative games you
know like everybody on the rapture gone
home i think if they're done well they
can they can achieve like really
impactful messages and stories but i'm
just wondering if it's enough to pull me
in as a Batman fan and if you're a
telltale fan whether that'll pull you in
as well I'm kind of wondering if they're
balancing those two camps well I mean I
think if you're a Batman Finn you're
definitely gonna want to play this I was
actually talking to one of my good
friends he loves Batman and he's he's
absolutely in love with this like he
thinks it's fantastic if you're a
telltale fan you're probably gonna be
sick of this formula by now I think it
sounds like it doesn't really change all
that much like people who know telltale
games were gonna just like yep it's
another like just iteration of that same
formula which you know again I mean I'm
a tell soph and obviously and even I'm
like okay this is starting worth it and
like we really need some new ideas which
again is why I'm excited about walking
dead season 3 but as people have sex
it's become almost like a rallying cry
for people who aren't big on telltale
games that the end is the same no matter
what choices you make and that's true
for basically every single
he'll game like no matter what choices
you Nick no matter how the path branches
you ultimately end up with the same
destination and yeah they've got to
start doing things a little bit
different or even yeah a telltale fans
are just going to get totally burnt out
on it and maybe you're not meant to play
every single telltale Game maybe it's
like all your Batman fan play this one
like all your kid loves my craft play
this one you know if you're playing
every single one you'll get burned out
much more quickly very fast but still
even even if you're just picking and
choosing ones you play it's like it
really couldn't hurt for them to update
the way they do things it's great though
the writing maybe yeah Scott regardless
of your current backlog of games do you
plan on playing this uh i mean i would
love to someday but it's definitely not
top of the list for me like I like
Batman but I'm by no means like a
hardcore Batman fan and I've played a
lot of telltale games like I have so
much other stuff to get through yeah
like I saw I saw him play Doom I really
want to play Doom for example like just
this may in particular this year there
were so many big releases that this one
is like I'll play it someday like it
would be on Steam sale something like oh
god never play Batman I'll totally play
it cuz i love telltale and i'm sure i'll
enjoy it sure but yeah there's nothing
about this particular series that has me
like really thrilled and excited yeah
well anyway i think i'm sort of
borderline i don't think i'll get to any
time soon like like you Scott or Jake I
don't know to endlessly positive note i
will say that i love that they are
focusing on Batman or on a Bruce Wayne I
love that there's like political
intrigue that it's not just about Batman
that it is about the full character I
think that was a really genius joy so if
there if there is a reason to play this
game that's it yeah I mean judging by
reviews of Suicide Squad d seniors can
take any help they can get so but anyway
yeah that is telltale the Batman Batman
the tell-tale series episode one realm
of shadows you can check out tomorrow
saenz review on gamespot even an 8 out
of 10 you really liked it tell us what
you think are you interested for more
telltale games you interested for this
specific one walking dead season 3 like
Scott said leave your comments in the
section below on YouTube or gamespot and
tell us what you think
you